Accountable care organizations are a key
feature of the new Affordable Care Act,
whose design is in part derived from
the PGP demo we just discussed.
There are currently a few hundred
ACOs being formed, or in operation.
32 select pioneer ACOs are piloting
an even more advanced approach.
Like the Marshville Clinic,
pioneer ACOs must use advanced health
IT to manage entire populations
of patients in a coordinated
manner to electronically
exchange healthcare data.
They must have the ability to
share performance feedback.
They must provide a portal providing
access to patients to their own data.
And they must have a demonstrated
ability to coordinate care.
So which of the following is
the most advanced approach
to pay-for-performance?